alors michel mercier vous avez fait
beaucoup de choses par amour vous est
même resté une fois 22 jours sans manger
par amour c'est vrai et alors interview
par amour
est-ce que parmi vous seriez prête à
vous déguiser en elton john bah non
apparemment on va pas me voir est-ce que
par amour vous seriez prête à cacher
quelqu'un qu'il vient de tuer par amour
impossible
est-ce que par amour ou soyez prêtes à
vous mettre à la drogue
sûrement pas ah bon vous l'avez pas
vraiment là bas quand on aime
il ya des choses qui est un bon est-ce
que parent pour que vous soyez prêtes à
prendre 17 kg sûrement pas j'essaye
d'aller perdre alors là c'est bien parce
que rose par amour vous seriez prête à
embrasser cent fois ses chaussettes
sales pas vraiment par amour
bon ok d'accord seul hockey d'amour à
ses chaussettes sont propres c'est mieux
salle de gym de cours on vous a pris si
que c'était des chaussettes sales elle à
dakar ok ok est-ce que par amour vous
seriez prête à accepter quelques petites
infidélités
non jamais non j'ai accepté cette
épreuve donc par amour vous accepteriez
pas qu'il est une maîtresse après j'ai
dit que je te demande quand il en avait
je ne savais pas quand même si c'était
terminé
auparavant je lis pas prêtes à vivre à
trois avec la mettrai jamais est-ce que
par amour
vous seriez prête à fréquenter des clubs
échangistes si angélique au kit kat
est-ce que par amour ou seriez prête à
devenir son esclave sexuelle
c'est mon jeu est-ce que par amour vous
seriez prête à vendre votre corps pour
lui non mais c'était touche l'argent
pour une fois
je ne suis pas